exercise equal size equal science then
really need to go down the pension I
think must must must be done it if
before you like you know not option
anymore
it's kind of like writing an essay in
English and not giving in spaces between
the words okay you are trying to
communicate that you understand what's
going on and you know what processes put
together the answer that you can be very
precise down the page I said I was gonna
collect three books today I still
haven't told you they are in the future
like cuz I'm saying this right now if
you've read your own sites across the
page in a desperate attempt to save
space I'm gonna say don't do that
anymore so that's the first thing please
don't do it it's just barely over
secondly I'm not gonna finish solving
this question normally but I just want
to show you the general strategy right
one two three full fractions first do I
really want to multiply by not just look
at it for a second we want to come in
denominator right how did we get 15
before how do we conjure up that double
we did 3 times 5 right - if they it
worked out it was fun okay now here 2
times 4 times 6 times 3 I think is 144 I
think okay crush like there's no mom
like I can tell you can do with it but
why right don't if it's a much smaller
number I can choose but we'll do the job
for me okay
is something that all four of these will
divide through by the smallest number I
can what do we do well looks like it'll
work for me right any number less than
12 one of these will not work out
if I do this by 12 I'll get it if I do
this by 12 all get on its on the butter
12 on the top that'll be three right OC
12 here cancels with the seats of leaves
me with two and then twelve he will they
be with then he just need to collect
like tubs not a charge but choose the
number every 12 these all water